and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist you know today we're gonna
talk about questioning we're talking
about questioning religion we're gonna
talk about questioning atheism we're
gonna talk about questioning belief
systems we're gonna talk about finding
peace with today's guests Irwin McManus
who is the founder of mosaic which is
right across the street from here very
convenient right well thank you for
being here today
I'm so glad to be here to travel all
this way the whole block now Irwin is
the author of 12 books including the new
book the way of the warrior if you're
watching this on youtube you can see it
right here
and there's so much that we want to talk
to you about today I want to dive deep
into the book I want to answer some
audience questions that we have and I
thought we could probably start well at
the beginning the beginning is often a
good place to start you actually start
your book with with an amazing line I'm
gonna read a little bit from the first
page here the warrior is not ready for
battle until they have come to no peace
for all the wars that have ever been
waged from the beginning of time we're
first born in a person's heart we have a
history of war because our souls are at
war we have conflicts because our hearts
are conflicted love that line yeah we
have conflict because our hearts are
conflicted one more line here every war
every conflict every act of violence
exists because our souls rage now just
earlier this month there was a mass
shooting in Ryan's in my hometown we're
from Dayton Ohio and two blocks from the
last house I lived in in in Dayton Ohio
nine people were murdered and another 27
people injured and this when I read this
line it reminded me of that there is a
war sort of going on inside Wow why are
we what's going on inside us one thing
that's really confounded me by the way
it's great to be here with you guys
is that humans are an incredible species
I mean we're the only species that ever
harnessed fire and electricity they were
the only species that invents the
internet invents the cell phone invents
Pizza and thank God for beads yeah there
you go
and with I mean we can figure out how to
explore the oceans and leave the
atmosphere and we cannot figure out how
to create peace mmm
and how is it possible that we can be so
inventive so creative so extraordinary
as a species and yet this thing that we
all desperately need and long for we
seem incapable of creating and not only
that but every environment we think
would eliminate violence actually seems
to almost perpetuate it we live in a
society with so much freedom so much
opportunity we're not for most Americans
there's not massive oppression but there
is something in the environment that we
create it creates an internal volatility
and and so some of it I think is that we
have to take some time and ask the
essential questions what is it that the
human soul needs whether you believe in
in a transcendent reality whether you
believe that we're created by God or not
there's something about the way humans
are designed that can move us to what we
would call in humanity and I think is
kind of odd because if you look at a
killer whale eat a seal and play with it
before it eats it or a tiger chased out
a gazelle we never think it's an animal
we never think it's outside of its
nature but with humans we can look at an
act think to ourselves that Acton Dayton
was inhumane right and that wouldn't say
a lion was in Lion life and so that
tells me whether you believe in God or
not you actually have this transcendent
sense of a higher essence of humanity
that we're somehow beneath our intention
because you cannot do something that's
inhumane if it's actually our intention
if it's our design it's even like
thinking about things being unnatural my
wife's from the Mount of North Carolina
she grew up at a farm
I'm kind of a I'm a City rat I mean it's
a that's why I've been all my life you
know I'm from San Salvador and then
lived in Queens and I live in Miami
and I and I live in LA and I love cities
and and one day we were traveling
through Arkansas or somewhere in the in
the middle of the country and it's all
the same to me
and we were quiet and there are all
these trees and all this wilderness and
and I broke the silence by saying look
at all this undeveloped land and I went
off the room fires she was like this is
not undeveloped land these are trees
these are trees God created trees and
and I looked at I said honey if there is
no God cities are just our honeycombs
mmm there are colonies when you think of
cities as being outside of nature you're
actually think of humans being outside
of creation that somehow there's
something transcendent about humans and
so if we're nothing but an advanced
version of all the species on this
planet if there is nothing divine
nothing transcendent you cannot say
cities are not natural yeah we're in the
middle of a colony right now of a comb
and just like silkworms quite silk
humans create futures mm-hmm beautiful
so so the reason that I wanted to talk
to you today and our good friend Lewis
Howes connected us thank thanks to Lewis
for making that happen and when you and
I talked on the phone I it was shortly
after I had a meeting with a guy named
Eric Weinstein he is a mathematician he
is he works at teal capital and one
thing that fascinated me about him is he
is an atheist but he goes to synagogue
every weekend and I it reminded me of
something I heard about you because I
know about mosaic it's right across the
street from here and I walked past it
all the time and I I see it's very
vibrant especially on Sundays they take
up the parking in our garage here
because you have so many people there
but I heard you say that you know you're
a church that has an extraordinary
number of atheists you have not just
ladies but people with different beliefs
and that's the one thing that Ryan and I
really
we appreciate about each other Ryan and
I have tend to have similar values but
we have radically different beliefs
and I thought to myself how could this
guy Eric not be a believer but also go
to effectively church every weekend and
and the answer came to me because I
realized like oh it's not just that it's
there's a sense of community that's
happening there that you probably don't
get elsewhere
I think it's Alan de Pathan that I heard
years ago at Ted and he he's an atheist
who advocates for religion and he thinks
that atheist should have churches and
and and I thought so interesting here's
an atheist
who's for religion and I am a Christian
who's against religion and he doesn't
believe in God and He wants religion and
I believe in God and I don't want
religion in fact of anything I've
probably created a great deal of
controversy in my life by being so anti
religion and years and years ago I think
I was really despised for a statement
that I was held accountable for that the
greatest enemy to the movement of Jesus
was Christianity and the problem is that
I actually did say it and I've most
quoted a lot in my life but I actually
did say that's and I do powerful and so
people come yes because when I didn't
grow up in in any kind of really
organized religion any kind of faith I
certainly didn't grow up anywhere near
Christianity in that sense and my mom
bought a Buddha home we were Buddhists
at a very early age and then and then
she moved toward Judaism we became more
Jewish and and my um my grandfather took
me to a place where he said a nine year
boy died and he was reincarnated and
that would came my grandfather so my
grandfather was an atheist who believed
in reincarnation and because Buddhism is
atheistic and a lot of people are
unaware of that you know and and then my
grandmother's Roman Catholic but she
never went to Mass so she had no trust
for any institutions and no free end and
so she would never get it put us near a
priest and so I grew up in that kind of
environment and I think my real father
was Jewish and and so you have all this
combination of belief systems and one of
the things that really struck me is that
a lot of times we try to focus on faith
connecting us to God but really the most
tangible thing it does is connect us to
each other
and it gives us hopefully not
it becomes the worst of religions when
it gives us rules on how to relate to
each other yeah
it becomes the best of spirituality when
it gives us values for relating to each
other about some of those values I want
to talk about service and contribution a
bunch of the stuff but we do have some
questions here from our audience so
let's dive into those or our first
question today is from Jonathan in Waco
Texas mainly I'm curious about bringing
minimalism into communities to say for
church groups in a small group sessions
and things like that have you had any
experience in that in an actual church
or religious setting and I'd love to
hear from you know those experiences or
any of the experiences of your listeners
I feel like definitely a lot of a lot of
the tenets of minimalism are certainly
compatible in that arena just not sure
how to go about implementing it I love
this question from Jonathan because how
often do people come up to us and
they're like you know Josh and Ryan you
are doing the work of Jesus Christ and
then kind of give us a wink and then
someone will come up to us and they'll
say you know what you guys you are doing
the work of the Buddha and we really
really appreciate that and it's funny
because when I think about minimalism
that is the one thing I feel like every
religion has in common every major
religion I grew up but Jehovah's Witness
which is you know a Christian kind of
based religion a little bit more
hardcore than most Christian religions
but but I grew I grew up Christian and I
really appreciated the values I took
away from that I mean I wouldn't be Who
I am today if I didn't grow up in that
organization I am not advocating for
that organization I have no part of that
organization anymore but what I do
appreciate are the lessons that I
learned and I think that minimalism is
one of those things that I looked at and
I was like oh here's some here's a set
of values that I can really take from
and I can apply these to my life without
having to have a you know a defiant or
I'm sorry a definite name of this
religion that I'm practice
so I'm with you or when like I am I'm
not anti religious in the sense that I
think religion is by and far you know
more harm than it is good I think it
actually is probably more good than it
is harm but I certainly want to avoid
any divisive 'no sand I think that's
what religion creates a lot now whether
it's you know if you have a really
devout Jewish person in the room a
really devout Christian in the room a
really devout Buddhist in the room a
really devout Muslim in the room they
are all going to in and they're you know
if they're really truly practicing the
religions they're all gonna be kind to
each other but inside they're good
they're all thinking well I have the
right religion and that's still to me is
a bit divisive but but minimalism
Jonathan answered your question yes like
minimalism I think it can be applied to
it can be brought into churches it can
be it could be brought to atheists but
yeah I think when you look at Buddha
Jesus Muhammad Confucius they all have
the same thing in common and they all
give that that same advice of like live
a simple life I think we're talking
about intentionality here right now
that's what you talk about and a lot of
your work is intentionality and I pulled
this from your website you have your
core values that are that are listed
there can we talk a little bit about
those values because you share them
openly obviously and and and I saw them
and like I was like wait a minute number
five here's creativity is the natural
result of spirituality and I heard you
discuss this with your son you have a
podcast that you do with with Aaron
called battle-ready
and it disagrees with me about
everything but can we can we talk about
that because I don't make that natural
leap right away creativity is the
natural result of spirituality can we
talk about that a little bit yeah when I
first penned those words I did not have
any adherence and in fact I had a double
amount of opposition both from the world
of faith and in the the secular world
and there would be you I'm from Jordan
Peterson who would disagree dramatically
to probably the most popular pastors a
time
and the world who would disagree and so
I think it's interesting a lot of
atheists and Christians actually agree
on this that humans are not creative to
disagree with you and and and ironically
the the deterministic framework for a
scientific determinism believes that
creativity is an illusion that it does
not exist that everything is
mathematical that everything is caused
in a fact and in at the National
Conference about ten years ago on
scientific determinism they said that
freewill creativity and spirituality do
not exist that they're illusions on in a
universe completely determined by math
mmm and that's really fascinating
because growing up I would have thought
atheists would be for creativity and
Christians were clearly against it and
religion seemed to be against it to me
religion was about conformity about
control about shaping people through
guilt and shame and limiting human
uniqueness and human creativity which
made me opposed to those kinds of
movements and now it's been a huge shift
and and I've been a small part of that
shift but atheism now believes that
creativity is an illusion
and I I actually think that it's a part
of the human structure that humans can
actually materialize the invisible that
what humans can do different than any
other species and some of us because
being a part of the Ted community for 20
years everyone advocates for some
species and I kept I would go to home to
my wife and tell her I need a species
you know everyone has one and then I
realized I've been studying humans all
my life and people think I've been
studying God all my life I've not been
studying God all my life I've been
studying humans all my life and and one
of the things that makes this really
distinct isn't the way in the way that
bees create hives and ants creat
colonies humans create futures that we
don't even think about it happens so
naturally that we choose and it
catalyzes the future and we choose and
eliminates a future and and I I think
this is the part of the creative essence
of being human that humans are imagined
to imagine and created to create and and
that's why in an earlier because
in Seoul I talk about how humans are
both a work of art and artists at work
the humans can imagine something and so
even though I know the theme of this is
being minimalist I actually I would say
that for me that my driving intention is
to convince people their generative that
humans can actually create and if you
create by accident you may create what
you regret and so there has to be an
intentionality around your actions so
that you can create a better humanity
right now we're living inside of
someone's imagination and for me one of
the best examples of that is when Barack
Obama took the oath of office and became
president United States so no matter
what your political position is he was
walking inside of the dream of el McKay
jr. who said I have a dream for one man
one day we will not be measured by the
color of our skin by the concert of a
character and I'm going Barack Obama is
literally walking inside of the
imagination of MLK and even though our
imaginations aren't perfect we're
sitting in a room right now that was
imagined by Jefferson and imagined by
watching and imagined by Adams or
sitting a nation that's closer to what
was imagined by Lincoln and every time
people who intend good live passive
lives those who have malice have more
intentionality in creating what's in
their imagination and so Hitler imagined
the world and violently tried to impose
it on humanity and today and this is
what frustrates me about about faith is
that I would I stepped into Christianity
and it was always this passive almost
victimized perspective about the future
God do something God do something God do
something and I kept hearing this
narrative going wait a minute people who
do not believe in God do not wait for
permission to create the future they
imagine but you're sitting around
imagining that God's going to do
something if you just ask him and you
need to actually realize that you are if
you believe in God then you have to
believe you're created to create and
that we are the instruments from which
the future emerges regardless of your
beliefs you need to intervene in your
own life is essentially what you're
saying there as opposed to waiting for
someone else to to intervene No
Salvador's born in San Salvador and
and and we live in a very dangerous city
so some very little time outside so from
the age of three I was playing chess
that was level that was my sport and my
grandfather I was very competitive he
would check make me in six moves you
know five moves seven moves eight moves
whatever and I would cry because I was
you know five and I would say let me
move and he would always tell me when
you learn to move you can have a move
and he taught me very early on in my
life that my future would expand by the
wisdom of my choices mm-hmm and and that
my future would be eliminated by the
foolishness of my choices and and I
think a lot of times people of faith try
to maintain a superstitious view of how
reality happens and and you know and so
there's a part of me that I'm a person
who has deep faith but I'm really a
person who lives in the reality of life
all of them and I think it's important
yeah I that most religious people had
that attitude because I have an issue
with faith too with the extent of you
know you think about what's going on
with our environment yeah
I'm not even talking about global
warming I'm not even talking about you
know climate change I'm just talking
about if you look at you know with 50%
of the rainforest gone 90% of Monarch
butterflies gone our streams being
polluted all of these things I was
raised to not worry about it I was
raised to believe that one day someone
with Jesus was gonna come back and he
was going to correct all of our mistakes
and whether that happens or not that
that narrative doesn't really make a lot
of sense to me it's like it would be
like it because you know God made us in
His image it would be like you know if a
parent never had the child to clean up
their own room and just always
constantly did everything for that child
to the point where the child didn't know
how to do anything so I totally agree
like we we do have to take some
responsibility for what our actions are
but faith sometimes I think he can
really can stilt our development almost
yeah it's almost as if the narrative was
you can live in a sewer cuz one day
Jesus is gonna come and clean it up
right
and before I ever believed anything
about Jesus
I had a value for the environment and I
couldn't understand how people who who
actually had a worldview that we've been
entrusted with creation would have a
lower view for caring for creation than
the person who didn't even know God you
know I Drive an electric car and a part
of that is because I can I mean I know a
lot of people can't afford one yeah and
a lot of people cannot but I feel like
for me I have an opportunity to have
zero carbon footprint on this planet
when I Drive and I feel like that's a
part of ironically it's it's almost like
reverse minimalism you know I spent more
money so that I could have less impact
yeah yeah and I think you have to ask
the question what can you do but I just
I love this planet mm-hm I don't
understand how you could believe in God
I believe God created this planet and
then that loved this planet yeah and
want to take care of the water and the
atmosphere and and that doesn't make any
sense to me at all yeah me neither
when we talk about what it means to live
a meaningful life ultimately we're often
talking about it means aligning your
actions with your values and what you're
talking about there is you've aligned in
action with your values youyou've been
intentional with that decision that
you've made now also you have the
resources to be able to afford that and
I think that's great
Jonathan I'm going to send you a copy of
Urban's book the way of the warrior I'm
also going to send you a copy of our
book our first book minimalism live a
meaningful life because in there we
talked about the five fundamental or
foundational values in our own lives
health relationships creativity growth
and contribution I think you'll find
value in that so John if you if you
could reach out to Jonathan send them a
copy of the way of the warrior also send
them a copy of minimalism if you like
our podcast you'll like the audio book
version of that or if you want the book
book or the eBook version we're happy to
send you those as well Ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media and did we
do so or when we are at the minimalists
on Twitter Facebook and Instagram you
are at our window Manas on on all the
relevant platforms no and and we follow
you over there
and so what we try to do during this
lightning round as we answer folks
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response all right we
don't actually have to do that we just
ramble on a bit Shawn makes it look
really pretty in the show notes he
copies out it tweezers our answers out
post them in the show notes so people
can share our pit the answers on social
media Rio it's our first question our
first question is from Joshua hook to
what extent is faith compatible with
doubt so Erwin yeah I know you talked
about this you know doubt and faith and
and how there they are well they are
compatible in a way they're not just
compatible they're essential mmm without
doubt there is no faith there's just
belief he's being pursued that was
awesome well let me let me expand on on
my thoughts on this really quickly my
pithy answer is we must question what we
hold close otherwise we cling to
everything and and I think that if we've
been sold something if we've been told
something since we were young and then
we refuse to question and then how how
strong is our conviction really right if
we're just given some template and then
we're told not to question it then I
think we're gonna have a really weak
faith in whatever it is is that fair
yeah absolutely III think a person
doesn't doubt doesn't think the answer
is faith and doubt are two sides of the
same coin
it's funny cuz my read this question I
almost didn't really understand it cuz
I'm like what does doubt have to do with
faith but then I realized like doubt and
faith it really is this at least the way
I take it is it's this feeling that I
get it's going with my gut and a lot of
the times I forget where you mentioned
in your book but it's like tens of
thousands of negative thoughts that
enter our mind every single day that was
a fascinating quote stat here 60,000
thoughts a day
80% are negative
it's crazy so so we're bombarded with
48,000 negative thoughts a day like it's
it's actually no wonder Dayton happened
right right yeah so so for me it's like
we have to it's okay to have doubts it's
okay to have faith but to hold on to
those loosely and sometimes we have to
doubt our doubts and sometimes leave to
doubt our faith but I think you have to
push harder it's not just okay to have
doubts it's a it's not okay to not have
doubts man Shawn's gonna have like a
million tweetable answers here all right
our next question is from Tabitha my
parents disapprove of my religion I come
from back I come from a Baptist family
and I desperately want my parents
approval but I'll never have it as a
Buddhist any tips you have Buddha sat at
your church we do and I someone like I'm
accused all the time of being a Buddhist
[Laughter]
if someone like Tabitha shows up and she
asks you this question you know my
parents disapprove of my religion or my
way of living or whatever what do you
say to someone like her
well one be grateful you have parents
yeah I never knew my father
and it was always a vacuum in my own
life wanting to know him just a little
bit and and I think one of the
challenges in life is not to live your
life for someone else's expectations and
I turned 61 this next week and and when
people ask me if there's something I
could change I said yes I would I would
worry less about the opinions of others
about my own life and you need to live a
life of intention that a life of
obligation yeah we're often chained by
our own obligations yeah we we create
these these obligations and then wear
them like a like a dog collar or
something and and realize like I put
this collar on myself in the first place
my pithy answer is compromising our
values to gain approval as a recipe for
discontent so I sort of echoes what what
you're saying they're like yeah if we're
always like pinging around like what
does this person they're gonna be what
is this
it's easy to do that because you get
instant gratification right which is is
in the moment feels good but if we're
just pinging around like a like a ping
pong ball or a pinball machine we're
never gonna be grounded and we're not
gonna feel contented by it by those
actions I think yeah
tabatha the only approval you need is
your own and you know my I do not have
the approval of my parents um I
definitely want it just like tabatha
does if I live the way my dad wanted me
to it would be very disingenuous life if
I live the way my mom wanted me to it
would be a very disingenuous life I have
to look in the mirror and feel good
about what I'm doing and when we have
relatives who don't support us it is
very very difficult I don't want to
undermine that but you're not you're
gonna live a happier life if you're
fulfilling your own expectations rather
than fulfilling other people's
expectations we can tweet that to Shawn
but I'll tell you what you just said man
about appreciating your dad like I've
got I've got a really I got a lot of
anger towards my dad that I've learned
how to deal with but what you just said
about just appreciating having known him
a little bit you have no idea how much
that like totally melted away some of
that anger I really appreciate them yeah
I'm in the same boat like I never really
knew my dad I mean he was around tall's
about three and so I what memories the
memories I do have or like of him with
my mom fighting and so like yeah I don't
have any real good memories and then
from there he he he he took a bad turn
was schizophrenic and had a lot of
issues but I think about that now like
you know my mother died when I was when
I was 28 and and that actually I'm
grateful for that in many ways because
it started this whole minimalism journey
made me start to question what my life's
focus was because I realized I was
focused on the wrong stuff the sort of
ephemeral pleasures the the the status
the trinkets the the average American
household has 300 thousand items in it
and I was trying to have more than that
because you know in order to be
successful you need those trinkets now
remember we have a bunch of more
questions here surprise questions that
Shawn got together for us we're gonna be
answering some of these coming up do
minimalism and religion walk
hand-in-hand or are they completely
different what are your thoughts on the
commodification of religion in the
United States how can i bar with my
spouse when they've walked away from
faith but I still believe how do I
explain my choice to question my
religion to loved ones also we're gonna
talk about toxic versus healthy religion
we're gonna talk about diversity we're
gonna talk about grace so we're gonna
talk about inner peace we're gonna talk
about the value of culture and so much
more also I want to talk to her when
about well he recently had a battle with
cancer that he won and a lot of lessons
were written about in the way the
warrior and also his previous book the
last arrow so I want to talk about that
as well and if you want to hear all that
you can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different much much longer maximal
episode on the minimalists private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about a whole bunch of
stuff we don't usually talk about in
public Ryan this week was we just
finished it with with Aaron and I can
tell you that we talked about a whole
lot I mean it went long it went in-depth
it was it was really meaningful you know
senator I was I was expecting to have a
similar conversation with him like we
had with Rob Bell it was two completely
different conversations yeah it was
great in fact we even talked a lot about
Rob on there and we talked about him
being a heretic and how people you know
question him anyway I won't get into too
much of it we've already given you a
preview there just so you know patreon
is the best way for us to fund this
podcast and keep it 100 percent
advertisement free also when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that it plays in your
favorite podcast app so whatever podcast
app you're using to listen to this
you'll get a private link so that our
regular private episodes will show up
right next to our minimal episodes that
you're listening to right now you can
find all the details and all the good
stuff including an additional private
podcast episode ever
week over at the minimalists comm /
support also just so you know we're
capping our patreon audience over at
over there at 6,000 people so get in
there while you can Ryan what else you
got for us being informed is more
important than ever so I want to
encourage people to read more and get
informed and hey you can do that by
getting her one's book the way of the
warrior I want to talk about what I
really loved about this book ma'am is
that this book I would recommend for
anyone who feels like they have just
gotten the snot beat out of them their
whole life and they're like for anyone
who has given up or as close to giving
up like that's who this book is for when
I read it I was thinking about I was
thinking about some some relatives and I
won't call them out specifically but I'm
certainly gonna send this to a few
relatives who I know or they're waiting
for someone to come and save them that's
not a hint towards Jesus they're just
anyone and what urlan does is he really
lays it out on how you can save yourself
and you can still have faith and save
yourself so yeah check out that book get
informed it's it's a great book and oh I
also got some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hey guys my name is Jenny and I'm
calling from Sheboygan Wisconsin I
wanted to share a tip and trick with
minimalist that have a family my husband
and I recently became a family of three
welcomed their son Micah into the world
six months ago and adding a mother being
to our lives can add a great deal of
physical items and items that are out
growing really quickly to honor our
family's minimalism efforts and living
within our one family income needs we
met and went to a family member who has
a son one year older than our son Micah
we asked them if we could borrow their
baby clothes and toys that they were
storing in their basement and Ben just
in case they had another baby boy so we
thought that we could use them now
rather than them just collecting dust in
their basement we have saved a great
deal of time and money by borrowing
these items and in turn we're storing
them in our basement as the family has a
smaller home and doesn't have space and
they didn't want to pay to rent a space
we have even started buying bigger
clothes and gifting them to the family
whereas they will become hours in the
future when our son goes onto that side
so we're creating this baby boy Cole is
moving hard drilled and getting the most
out of each item by sharing them with
multiple families this could work with
family members or friends co-workers of
any listeners that needed tip it's a
win-win for everybody
hi guys this is Virgo from Atlanta
Georgia I just wanted to call as a
longtime barista I have a couple tips
about coffee I know you guys are coffee
people and own your own coffee shop
which is great by the way I love bandit
I just wanted to tell listeners that
there's a really awesome coffee
subscription service called trade coffee
com
you can go in and put in your
preferences and what kind of you know
profiles you like and you can put in you
know what your brewing method is or
whatever and they will customize kind of
I guess what coffee to send you and how
often you can tell them if you want it
every week or every two weeks like I do
or every month or however often you want
to receive your bag of coffee it's great
roasted to order specialty coffee and I
have gotten a lot of value out of it and
every bag is between eighteen and twenty
two dollars usually so it's it's about
what you would pay at a specialty shop
for a bag of coffee and you can find new
Roasters to support which is awesome the
other thing I wanted to share is
TerraCycle calm which is a service where
you buy basically like a box and then
you fill it with your used coffee bags
and they will recycle them for you and
you know anybody who drinks a lot of
coffee knows like it sucks to throw away
all those bags but you know what are you
going to do with them right so you can
recycle them with this service it's a
bit of an investment usually it's like
thirty five dollars for a small pouch or
you can go bigger I think the biggest
option is like a pallet which is eight
hundred ninety nine dollars if you want
to do that but yeah it's just an option
for recycling those bags thanks guys all
right so thanks again to Aaron McManus
for joining us today you can check him
out at mosaic org that his is his
organization on the maximal episode we
also talked about they're here to stay
campaign if you want to learn more about
that its mosaic dot org slash here to
stay you can check out his book the way
of the warrior and all of his other
books as well at urban mcmanus comm you
can also follow him on social media at
Irwindale quick four right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist I think this
probably the last time we're going to
talk about this because we are so close
now Ryan it has been a difficult year
for our hometown getting Ohio there was
a tornado yeah
beginning of the summer yeah actually 14
tornadoes to be specific
all across Dayton just so much
devastation across Dayton and then a few
months later a mass shooting two blocks
from the last house I lived in and
Dayton in fact the first house I grew up
in just two blocks away and mass
shooting nine people murdered and 27
people were were injured and it's just
been a rough year for Dayton and they
have all kinds of other problems as well
the opioid epidemic and another big
problem that we're trying to help solve
and that is the fact that one of the
largest food deserts in the country was
in Dayton Ohio the west side of Dayton
where roughly 40% of the residents of
Dayton live does not have a single
grocery store and we're trying to change
that we've raised ninety six thousand
dollars right now oh man we're four
thousand dollars away from having the
final hundred thousand dollars to build
this grocery store with the folks at the
Jim City Market now this is a
not-for-profit co-op this isn't your
traditional Kroger or whatever this is a
grocery store those are going to focus
on providing healthy food to the
community but also food healthy food
education to the community which is
equally important if you want to
contribute to that it's really simple
$1 $10 $20 a million dollars but really
we only need $4,000 yeah that's true
$4,000 whatever you want to contribute
Ryan and I have contributed $25,000 of
our own money as well you can go to the
minimalists comm slash Dayton you can
see the little thermometer there we are
so so close and we need your help to get
the little last bit to build this
grocery store and you can follow us on
social media to keep up to date on the
progress as well if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at you
tube comm /the minimis if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
and you also receive our simple Sunday
emails for added value this week I
thought it'd be appropriate since our
one was here his daughter her name is
Mariah her stage name is Raya
she's a super talented musician I just
started listen to her
her new project this week it the project
itself is called heartbreak magic but
she has this great song called in my
dreams
now Ryan you and I are fans of andrew
bell and like amy stru and her music
reminds me a lot it's in that same thing
it's really good I can't wait to check
it out yeah so let's let's let's finish
this episode today let's listen to in my
dreams from Ryan's new EP heartbreak
magic and if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time minimus